Jetzt wird es ganz interessant.
Es hat auf jeden Fall schon mal gelebt.
Aber die Frage ist: Lebt es wieder?
«Kotzen» die Leute dann hier an den Mülleimer?
Überall.
Wie viele davon hast du schon aus dem See geholt?
Ich habe aufgehört zu zählen.
Puh. Ich glaube, da hat es Fisch gegeben.
Da kommt es mir fast hoch.
Tipp von mir: Durch den Mund atmen.
Drei Tage unterwegs
im Kampf gegen Dreck und Abfall.
Das ist "Mona mittendrin".
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
Morgens um 4 Uhr auf leeren Magen Abfalleimer leeren.
Für Vito von der Stadtreinigung Zürich ist das der Alltag.
Für mich eindeutig weniger.
Du kannst ihn auch von unten packen
und runterziehen.
Wäh!
Hey ...
Gewöhnt man sich an den Gestank?
Mir ist das
noch gar nie so aufgefallen.
Dass es stinkt?
- Stinkt es für dich?
Das stinkt doch mega.
- Nein.
Doch.- Nein, da sind nicht viele
Esswaren drin. Das täuscht.
Aber es stinkt. Ah.
- Das täuscht.
Muss ich den zuschlagen?
Oder wie geht das?- Wenn möglich
nicht. Wir sind mitten im Quartier.
Es wäre nicht schlecht,
wenn du es mal sanft probierst.
* Klicken *
Perfekt.
Vito ist ein Routinier.
Er arbeitet seit acht Jahren beim
ERZ Entsorgung + Recycling Zürich.
Darum ist er härter im Nehmen
als ich, was den Geruch angeht.
Wir sind am Idaplatz,
wo die Leute in Corona-Zeiten
gerne ein paar Freiluftbiere trinken.
Was man hier gerade am Wochenende
an Erbrochenem findet -
das finde ich viel, viel schlimmer
als ein offenes Bier,
das von gestern Abend
hier drin liegt.
Dann kotzen sie jeweils
hier vorne ran?
Überall.
- Ohne Scheiss?
An die Haltestelle, an den Kübel,
auf das Trottoir, auf die Strasse -
wo sie halt gerade sind.
Wäh!
Den Aschenbecher
müsstest du auch noch leeren.
Den kannst du
einfach unten rausziehen.
* Lachen *
Sorry dafür.
Etwa so. Das war gemein,
ich hätte es dir zeigen können.
Dann kommt die nächste Aufgabe.
Wir sind noch nicht fertig.
Nur Kübel leeren reicht nicht.
- Okay.
Das ist ein Stein.
Den nehmen wir nicht.
Den kannst du lassen.
* Lachen *
Möchtest du ein Schoggistängeli?
Es ist noch ganz.
Der ganze Dreck soll weg sein,
wenn die Leute morgens aufstehen.
Das ist etwas,
das ich nicht verstehe:
Sieh dir das an.
Genau hier ist mir das mal passiert:
Ich nahm mit dem Rechen
die Zigaretten zusammen,
während eine junge Frau hier sass.
Sie hat dann aber ihre Zigaretten
trotzdem am Boden ausgedrückt,
anstatt zum Aschenbecher zu gehen.
Hat das Stil?
Für mich nicht,
aber ich darf leider nichts sagen.
Was heisst das?
- Ja, ich bin nicht ihr Papi.
Ich muss sie nicht erziehen und
sagen: "Das gehört in den Kübel."
Aber: "Ich putze hier
genau den Dreck, den du machst."
Dann kommt ein blöder Spruch:
"Wenigstens hast du was zu tun."
Es gibt viele, die denken,
dass wir so etwas zu tun hätten.
Obwohl es nicht so ist.
Das sind die neuen Zigaretten-
stummel, seit es Maskenpflicht gibt.
Die liegen auch überall rum.
Das finde ich noch fast ekliger
als Zigarettenstummel.
Gehen wir weiter.
- Ja.
Etwas in der Wärme.
- Ja, mir ist mega kalt.
Lange kann ich mich nicht aufwärmen.
In der Stadt Zürich muss man
viele Kübel leeren - insgesamt 4'000.
So, wieder dasselbe Spiel.
- Jawohl.
Wenn du eine Kübeltour machst,
leerst du bis zum Feierabend Kübel?
Ja.
Wird das nicht irgendwann langweilig?
Nein, du findest immer etwas Neues.
Gut, aber das sind ja nicht Dinge,
die man unbedingt finden möchte.
Nein, nicht unbedingt.
Aber du bist immer wieder
an einem anderen Ort,
du fährst hin und her, triffst Leute
und siehst Kollegen ...
Aber das ist eher ein Job, den man
macht, weil man sonst keinen findet.
Nein.
- Nicht?
Ich habe auch eine Lehre gemacht.
- Was?
Maler,
also eigentlich ziemlich kreativ.
Man muss irgendwann halt wissen,
was man möchte.
Ich war nicht der typische Junge,
der sagte,
er wolle Polizist oder Feuerwehrmann
werden.
Ich wollte es
immer etwas gemütlicher haben.
Ich wollte nichts Anstrengendes.
- Ja.
Kannst du verstehen, dass die Leute
ein negatives Bild davon haben
und denken, das sei ein Scheissjob?
- Ja, sicher.
Es ist Abfall, es ist dreckig, es
ist eklig. Das ist nicht für jeden.
Aber ich finde,
es gibt wirklich Schlimmeres.
Wäh!
Bei denen
muss man immer vorsichtig sein.
Das ist das Schöne:
Sie trinken sie nicht mal leer.
Ja, genau. Es tropft einem entgegen.
Nein, aber echt. Hey ...
Das war fast eine volle Dose, oder?
- Ja. Hey ...
Stellst du dir nie die Frage,
was für Leute hier sassen,
die ihren Arsch nicht hochkriegten,
um die Bierdosen
in den Kübel dort zu werfen?
Von jung bis alt,
gutaussehend bis schlechtaussehend -
da ist alles dabei.
Der nächste Kübel ist dort.
- Dort vorne ist auch einer.
Oder dort, wo das Auto steht.
Ich will nicht wissen,
wie es bei denen zu Hause aussieht.
Noch eine volle.
Aber sag mal ...
Schau: das perfekte Frühstück.
Wie spät ist jetzt? 7 Uhr?
- Fast.
Und wir haben schon
mein perfektes Frühstück gefunden.
Kaum geht die Sonne auf, ist
schon der halbe Arbeitstag vorbei.
Aber jetzt
sind die Strassen an der Reihe -
mit Putzwagen und Besen.
Ihr habt ja so richtige Hexenbesen.
Das passt irgendwie zu mir, nicht?
Wenn du davonfliegen könntest
vielleicht.
Rolf ist mein Kollege beim Wischen.
Sascha
sitzt in der Kehr-Saug-Maschine.
Wir sind im Langstrassenquartier
unterwegs.
(Mann) Wischen, wischen!
Hey ...
Hast du den gehört?
Ich habe nicht verstanden,
was er gesagt hat.
"Wischt mal, wischt mal!"
Ich finde es ziemlich respektlos, den
Leuten, die unseren Abfall wegräumen,
blöde Sprüche nachzurufen.
Was hast du schon alles erlebt
bei dieser Arbeit?
V.a. hier in der Langstrasse
treten sie auch gegen das Fahrzeug.
Sie beschimpfen uns
und rufen uns allerhand Sachen nach.
Was antwortest du da?
- Gar nichts.
Ich reagiere nicht. Das darfst du
nicht. Du machst es nur schlimmer.
Jeder sollte mal
eine Woche bei uns arbeiten ...
... und erfahren, wie das ist,
den Dreck von anderen wegzuputzen.
Denkst du,
dann würde man sich anders verhalten?
Dann würden sie das anders sehen.
- Auf jeden Fall.
Sie würden dann bewusster
damit umgehen, denke ich. Ja.
Abfall im öffentlichen Raum
wegzuputzen
kostet in der Schweiz
jährlich 200 Mio. Fr.
Die Zigarettenstummel alleine
kosten 53 Mio. Fr.
Weggeworfenes Geld.
Wäh, hey ... Okay, das ist ...
Ich habe mich schon
etwas an den Geruch gewöhnt.
Aber die Langstrasse
spielt in einer anderen Liga.
Aber hier merkst auch du,
dass es stinkt.
Langstrasse halt.
- Nennst du das Langstrasse?
Ist das das Parfüm der Langstrasse?
- Kann man so sagen.
Ich finde Vitos
Humor und Gelassenheit bemerkenswert.
Man braucht beides, um den Job
so gerne machen zu können, wie er.
Vito hat jetzt Feierabend.
Mich schickt er eine Runde weiter:
zum Putzen eines anderen Teils
des öffentlichen Raums.
An einem Ort, wo man es
nicht unbedingt erwarten würde.
Auf den Gewässern von Zürich.
Das ist Luis Becerra
von der Seereinigung,
der Kapitän auf dem Putzschiff.
Das gefällt dir, oder?
- Ja. Ja, ja. Ja. Das gefällt mir.
Dir auch, gib es zu.
- Doch, doch. Ich mache es gerne.
Sieh dir die Aussicht da an.
Die Berge dort hinten.- Ja.
Luis und seine Kollegen
putzen täglich den Zürichsee.
Wir haben gerade
die Meldung erhalten,
dass ein Elektrotrottinett
im Wasser liege.
Eines von denen,
das man via App mieten kann.
Siehst du etwas?
- Nein.
Habt ihr irgendwo
ein versenktes Trottinett gesehen?
(Mann) Leider nicht.
Da unten ist es.
- Ah, da ist es.
Genau.
Luis macht das nicht zum ersten Mal.
Ja aber, schau ... Hey ...
Es ist schwer, nicht?
- Mega schwer.
Hei, ei, ei. Ja, du.
Wie viele von denen
hast du schon aus dem See geholt?
Ich zähle nicht mehr.
- Ehrlich? Noch mehr als Velos?
Die werfen sie manchmal auch rein.
- Ja, Velos weniger.
Der Trend sind momentan diese.
- Ja.
Pro Woche fische ich bis zu 20 raus.
Hat das damit zu tun, dass
die eigentlich niemandem gehören?
Klar.- Dann ist es egal.
Dann kannst du es in den See werfen.
Und hier ist es praktisch.
Du kannst es einfach reinschieben.
Dann ist es passiert.
Was machst du damit?
- Ich bringe es ins Bootshaus.
Kann man das noch brauchen?
- Ich glaube nicht.
Jetzt gehen wir zur Quaibrücke.
- Jawohl.
Dort hat es sog. Badewannen.
Dort drin sammelt sich
immer viel Abfall an.
Ah, das ist hier?
- Genau, das ist da hinten.
Okay.
Das ist eben die Badewanne.
- Wäh.
Eine etwas grössere Badewanne.
- Ugh.
Wie gleichgültig und ignorant
gewisse Leute Dinge wegwerfen,
würde mich langfristig wütend machen.
Wie findest du das so,
dass die Leute einfach Flaschen
und alles in den See werfen?
Du bist der, der das dann rausholt.
Vom Trottinett bis zum ...
- Ja, also ...
Ich frage mich einfach, warum
die Leute das eigentlich machen.
Aber weisst du,
nach so langer Zeit ...
... fragst du dich nicht mehr
und wirst nicht mehr wütend.
Du sagst dir: "Das ist dein Job."
Und du machst es einfach.
Wenn ich nach Hause komme, habe ich
etwas gemacht, das Sinn macht.
Dann denke ich:
"Du hast etwas Gutes gemacht."
In dem Sinne,
dass ich etwas geputzt habe.
Für die Bevölkerung
oder für wen auch immer.- Ja.
Ich habe einfach ein gutes Gefühl.
Eine Aufgabe, die zufrieden macht.
Luis ist sich nicht zu schade
für die Arbeit mit Dreck.
Vor der Seereinigung hat er zehn
Jahre in der Kanalisation gearbeitet.
Das merkt man abends im Rücken, oder?
- Ja.
Es ist doch kein Schoggi-Job.
- Ich nehme alles zurück.
Die Schicht ist vorbei
und wir fahren zum Bootshaus
der Seereinigung, um abzuladen.
Das ist schwer.
Nach einem Tag Arbeit sieht Luis,
was er gemacht hat.
Beim Shutdown im letzten Jahr
haben wir uns gefragt,
welche Jobs es wirklich braucht.
Die Abfallentsorgung
ist auf jeden Fall systemrelevant.
Feierabend.
- Feierabend, genau.
Am nächsten Morgen im Hagenholz
am Stadtrand von Zürich.
Das ist die Zentrale
des Zürcher Abfallwesens.
Ich bin
für den Kehrichtlastwagen eingeteilt.
(Mann) So. Wir gehen los.
- Okay, los geht's.
(Frau) Ja, ist gut.
Wir hören uns später.
Ich arbeite als Abfallfrau -
oder Entsorgungslogistikerin,
wie man dem heute sagt.
Jetzt siehst du, wie wir arbeiten.
Du hast schönes Wetter erwischt.
Extra für mich.
- Ja.
Ich bin mit David Brassel und
Chauffeuse Claudia Stamm unterwegs.
Ist man immer zu zweit?
Zu dritt. Man muss immer ...
- Zähle ich auch?
Ja, sicher. Das siehst du dann.
- Ich zähle auch.
Du zählst auf mich.
- Ja, richtig.
Wir sind ein Team.
Das ist sehr wichtig.
Da ist der erste Container.
Wir sind schon hier.
David hat jahrelang
in der Gastronomie gearbeitet,
bevor er professioneller
Trittbrettfahrer wurde.
Beim ERZ schätzt er den sicheren Job
und die geregelten Arbeitszeiten.
Oh ja, ich glaube, hier gab's Fisch.
Nachdem wir ein paar Container
geleert haben, merke ich,
dass wir weniger als Dienstleistung
und mehr
als Hindernis gesehen werden.
Die hatten Geduld.
- Ja.
Das haben nicht alle.
- Nicht?- Nein.
Hupen viele?
- Ja, sie hupen und sind nervös.
Damit müssen wir rechnen.
Hast du das gesehen?
Der ist schon nervös.
Sicher? Hoi, Fredy.
- Der ist schon wütend.
Was hat er gemacht?
- Innerlich geflucht.
Wir machen ja auch nur unseren Job.
Es ist traurig,
dass sie keine Geduld haben.
Du erlebst das tagtäglich.
- Ja.
Man muss damit zurechtkommen.
Sie haben auch Abfall.
Wir entsorgen den
wie bei den anderen.- Ja.
Weisst du, was schlimm ist?
Ich bin genau gleich.
Nein? Mona ...
- Ja.
So nicht.
- Jetzt wo ich bei dir bin,
denke ich auch:
"Sorry, du musstest 2 Min. warten."
Aber sonst: "Scheisse,
da ist die Kehrichtabfuhr."
Wir arbeiten ja auch.
Wir müssen unseren Job machen.
Am Lichtsignal oder bei einem Unfall
musst du auch warten.
Warten gehört zum Leben, finde ich.
- Ja.
Davids Wunsch ist einfach:
ein bisschen mehr Verständnis
und ab und zu einen Daumen hoch.
Wo muss sie jetzt hinfahren?
- Sie muss hier runter.
Ah, hier hinten runter. Meine Güte.
- Genau.
Claudia
ist schon seit 20 Jahren beim ERZ.
Bei dir ist gut?
- Ja, bei mir ist immer noch gut.
Momentan ist sie die einzige Frau
bei der Kehrichtabfuhr.
Meine Güte.
Mit so einem 9-m-Gefährt
rückwärtszufahren ...
In eine Einfahrt rein ...
Gut, super.
Falls noch jemand sagen will,
Frauen könnten nicht parkieren.
Genau.
Die haben Claudia
noch nicht kennengelernt.- Richtig.
Der ist ziemlich schwer. Wenn man
ihn dort hochschieben müsste ...
Das wäre nicht einfach.
Statt der weissen Gebührensäcke sind
in diesem Container nur schwarze.
Schaust du da rein? Man dürfte
doch nur Züri-Säcke entsorgen.
Achtest du darauf, ob jemand
einfach etwas reingeworfen hat?
Betriebe können reinwerfen,
was sie wollen.- Ah, die roten.
Wir Schweizer klopfen uns
ja gerne auf die Schulter,
weil wir so gut recyceln.
Aber leider gehören wir auch in
der Abfallproduktion zur Weltspitze.
In Europa haben nur die Dänen und
Norweger noch mehr Siedlungsabfall.
Danach lassen wir
die da hinten durch.- Ja.
Hey. Einer, der grüsst. Danke.
Hast du das gesehen?- Ja.
Das macht dann Freude.
Siehst du, hier fängt es schon
mit illegalen Dingen an.
Aha!
Schwarze Säcke, Büchsen -
das gehört nicht rein.
Die bezahlen keine Sackgebühr?
- Genau.
Das legen wir mal zur Seite.
Dann müssen wir
den Kontrolldienst anrufen,
dass er vorbeikommen
und das kontrollieren solle.
Genau.
Ja hoi, hier ist Claudia.
Wir brauchen dich.
Wir haben schwarze Säcke gefunden.
Schaust du je nach Gegend?
Wenn du weisst, es könnte was haben?
Oder schaust du immer?
- Nein, ich schaue ab und zu.
Stichkontrollen.
- Ja.
Hier sind auch zwei drin.
Den auch lassen.
Da sind wieder zwei Säcke drin.
Boah!
Sali.
- Hallo.
Wir haben schwarze Säcke
und andere illegale Säcke gefunden.
Gut, okay.
- Ich bin Mona. Wer bist du?
Ich bin Thomas. Hoi.
- Hoi. Du bist der Kontrolldienst?
Ja. In Person.
Das kann man so sagen.
Ihr seid wie Privatdetektive.
- Ähnlich, ja.- Okay.
Also, komm.
- Schauen wir rein.
Da gehören eigentlich
nur Züri-Säcke rein.
Das ist nicht wirklich
ein Züri-Sack.
Breitest du das jetzt hier aus?
- Nein, im Auto.
Ich habe alles dabei.
Wir schlitzen auf ...
... und schauen im Sack,
ob wir Indizien finden,
die auf eine Person
schliessen lassen.
Du bist wirklich ein Detektiv.
Suchst du jetzt Adressen oder was?
- Adressen, Namen ...
Aber wenn jemand
illegal Abfall entsorgt,
wird er ja nicht so dumm sein
und seine Adresse reintun.
Doch, doch, wir finden alles.
- Sicher?
Ja.
- Okay.
Auch wenn sie denken, sie
hätten alle Adressen weggenommen,
haben sie vergessen, dass sie
letzte Woche beim Arzt waren
und dort
ein Medikament erhalten haben.
Auf dem Medikamentenpaket
ist meistens ein Name drauf.
Lohnt sich der Aufwand?
Lohnen vielleicht nicht unbedingt,
aber wenn wir sie erwischen,
werden sie angeschrieben.
Wir haben schon Signalwirkung,
wenn wir mit dem grossen Auto
unterwegs sind
und in die Quartiere gehen.
Da spürt man schon, dass
hinter den Vorhängen Leute sind.
Wirklich?
V.a. dort, wo wir immer wieder sind.
- Ja.
Wie oft rückt ihr aus?
Wir sind täglich unterwegs.
- Wirklich?
- Man findet jeden Tag etwas?
Ja.
- Okay.
Letztes Jahr gaben wir
ca. 1'000 Anzeigen raus.- Nein.
1'000 Anzeigen?
- Knapp 1'000 Anzeigen.
Ugh.
Du bist absolut emotionslos.
Ja, ja.
- Mir wird schon ein bisschen übel.
Ein kleiner Tipp:
Atme durch den Mund!
* Lachen *
Oh ja, jetzt kommen die Windeln.
Die DNA kontrollieren wir nicht.
- Ja.
Jetzt wird es interessant.
Es hat mal gelebt,
aber lebt es wohl schon wieder?
Aha!
Was ist das?
Ah! Oh-oh-oh! Eine Rechnung.
Oder was ist es?
- "Zweite Mahnung".
Das ist eine Adresse von hier.
Ich glaube schon.
- Die hier.
Ja.
Also, jetzt fülle ich das Formular
aus, das ich angefangen habe.
Züri-Sack-Container.
Das war ein 60-l-Sack.
Zeit: 15.10 Uhr.
Das hat dir keine Ruhe gelassen,
bis du es gefunden hast.
Ja.
- Du bist ein richtiger Bluthund.
Das wirst du. Ja.
- Sicher?
Das Schlimmste ist,
wenn du nichts findest.
Dann kommst du
völlig niedergeschlagen nach Hause.
Wenn du den ganzen Tag gearbeitet
und nichts gefunden hast.
Das ist nicht befriedigend.
Wie teuer wird das?
- Das kostet 320 Fr.
320 Fr.
- Ja.
Dafür hätte die Abfallsünderin 160
offizielle 35-l-Säcke kaufen können.
Wir fahren zurück ins Hagenholz.
Thomas entlädt
seinen handverlesenen Abfall.
Und auch Claudia und David
sind hier mit ihrem Abfall.
Was hier
in die gigantische Grube reinfällt,
wird danach
im Heizkraftwerk verbrannt.
Durchschnittlich 1'000 t pro Tag.
Die grosse Herausforderung
aus Umweltsicht
ist dabei
gar nicht die Entsorgung selber.
Die ist mittlerweile ziemlich
effizient und schadstoffarm.
Das ist gut.
- Boah, heftig.
Aber alles, was hier weggeworfen
wird, wurde ja mal hergestellt,
und hat Energie und Ressourcen
verbraucht.
Wir produzieren einfach
viel zu viel Abfall, oder?
Achtest du selbst darauf?
Ja, ich recycle auch -
wie es sich gehört.
Ich versuche, so wenig Abfall
wie möglich zu produzieren.
Aber manchmal geht es halt nicht.
Es ist halt alles verpackt.
Wenn du siehst, dass vor einem Haus
so ein Berg mit Säcken liegt ...
... verurteilst du niemanden dafür?
- Nein.
Du sagst nicht,
das seien alles Verschwender?
Es steckt ein System dahinter.
Wir müssten vielleicht langsam
etwas umdenken.
Aber alles braucht seine Zeit.
Es geht nichts von heute auf morgen.
Wir sind eine Konsum-
und Wegwerfgesellschaft -
viel kaufen und viel wegwerfen.
Unser Abfall füttert
das ewige Feuer des Hagenholz,
das Tag und Nacht brennt.
Am dritten Tag
bin ich an einem Ort eingeteilt,
den ich als Privatperson schon kenne:
Ich habe auch schon Dinge
im Recyclinghof entsorgt.
Guten Morgen. Du bist Michi, oder?
- Morgen. Genau.
Ich bin bei dir eingeteilt. Mona.
- Hoi. Jetzt kommen die Kunden.
Die kommen schon?
Kleider?- Wenn sie brauchbar sind,
dort in den TEXAID, bitte.
Danke.
- Bitte.
Michi
ist ein Urgestein im Recyclinghof.
18 Jahre arbeitet er schon hier.
Der kommt in den Elektroschrott.
Hey.
Hast du immer den Überblick?
- Ja, ich muss. Klar.
Aber es hat so viele Autos.
- Nein. Das ist nichts.
Was jetzt?
- Das sind Peanuts.
Das sind Peanuts?
Was wäre denn heftig?
- Wenn hier alles voll ist.
Wenn alle Parkplätze besetzt sind
und es eine Kolonne hat.
Gegen Ende Jahr
entsorgen sehr viele Leute Dinge.
Da gibt es Peaks, wo über
1'000 Fahrzeuge pro Tag kommen.
Es gibt anscheinend
ein emotionales Bedürfnis,
gegen Ende Jahr
sozusagen Tabula rasa zu machen.
Sie wollen zu Hause aufräumen
und Altlasten entsorgen.
Für den Seelenfrieden oder so. Ja.
Mir ging es auch so: Du kommst
beladen wie ein Sünder rein,
dann lädst du es ab
und bist ganz befreit.
Ganz genau.
- Du fährst befreit raus.
Wenn der Kunde
mit einem Lächeln rausfährt,
haben wir gute Arbeit geleistet.
- Ja.
Mittlerweile wird schon über
die Hälfte des Abfalls recycelt.
* Ruhige Musik *
Beim Abfallentsorgen
macht uns Schweizern
so schnell niemand was vor.
Das glaube ich. Das hoffe ich.
* Lachen *
Aber das Problem ist,
dass wir ja gar nicht erst
so viel Abfall produzieren sollten.
Genau. Ich arbeite
seit fast 20 Jahren hier.
Wenn ich einkaufen gehe, nehme ich
lieber mehr Geld in die Hand ...
... damit es nachhaltiger ist.
- Du achtest darauf?- Ja.
Ich kümmere mich auch gut
um die Dinge, die ich kaufe,
damit sie möglichst lange halten.
Ich denke, da steckt auch
eine gewisse Emotionalität dahinter.
Jeder Gegenstand
hat irgendwie auch eine Seele.
Irgendwie. Irgendwie.
* Er lacht. *
Ein schöner Gedanke von Michi,
dass jeder Gegenstand
so etwas wie eine Seele hat.
Vielleicht
trägt man den Sachen so mehr Sorge
und versucht sie zu flicken,
anstatt sie wegzuwerfen.
Die Stühle
gehören zu den Teilen mit Metall.
Grüezi.
Ich weiss, wo Karton hinkommt.
- Alles klar.
Wo kommt das hin? So Holzzeugs?
Abfall?
Okay.
Bei vielem, das entsorgt wird,
denke ich mir:
"Das könnte man noch brauchen."
Das Velo hier sieht z.B.
noch nicht wirklich alt aus.
Das Velo ist ein Beispiel,
das wir täglich erleben.
Die Leute bringen tolle Dinge
und bieten sie uns an.
Wir müssen sagen,
dass sie es hierlassen können,
wir es aber nicht nehmen dürfen.
Auch wenn du sagst,
du könntest das flicken,
darfst du es nicht mitnehmen?
- Nein. Nein.
Das ist verboten. Ich sehe
jeden Tag, was die Leute wegwerfen.
Da kommen mir z.T. die Tränen.
Das ist wirklich ...
Da fragt man sich immer wieder,
warum das jemand wegwirft.
Ich habe das Gesetz nicht gemacht.
Tatsächlich
schreibt die Abfallverordnung vor,
dass alle Dinge, die hierhergebracht
werden, entsorgt werden müssen.
Dafür bezahlt der Kunde.
Diese Verordnung wird nächstes Jahr
aber voraussichtlich geändert,
damit die Dinge
weitergegeben werden können.
Was macht ihr gerade?
Wir räumen unsere Wohnung.
Wir entsorgen alles. Alles muss weg.
Wir haben vieles verkauft.
- Warum?
Ab 1. April wohnen wir im Van
und gehen danach auf Europareise.
Wirklich?
- Ja.- Ja, alles muss weg.
Meine Güte!
- Ein richtiger Schnitt.
Wie fühlt sich das an?- Ich dachte
immer, wir hätten nicht so viel.
Als wir aber
mit Aussortieren anfingen,
wurde mir fast schlecht davon,
wie viel Besitz wir haben.
Ich finde es jetzt mega befreiend,
alles abzugeben.
Die beiden Traveller leben jetzt
mit einem Minimum an Dingen.
Also sicher mit weniger als den
durchschnittlich 10'000 Gegenständen,
die man
in einem Schweizer Haushalt findet.
Absperren.
- Achtung, was ist jetzt los?
Der Bagger macht Platz.
Der Haufen, der hier liegt,
wird nicht recycelt.
Alles Holz landet
im Bunker des Heizkraftwerks
und wird dort verbrannt.
Diese riesige Kralle
füttert das ewige Feuer.
Und oben im Turm sitzt der,
der den Kran bedient.
* Leise Rockmusik *
* Mona lacht. *
"Lärmwarnung, Joël am Kran".
"Lautstärke der Musik
könnte als hoch empfunden werden."
* Laute Rockmusik *
Joël, ich bin Mona.
- Hoi, Mona.
Darfst du so laut Musik hören?
Bis jetzt
hat noch niemand etwas gesagt.
Jesus ...- Du darfst
auf die Scheibe stehen. Sie hält.
Sicher?
- Sie hält auch bei mir.
Hey ...
Wie klein die 35-l-Säcke
von hier aussehen!
Der Greifer ist so gross, dass er
locker drei Autos heben könnte.
Joëls Aufgabe ist, den Abfall
zu mischen, damit er optimal brennt.
So wird Fernwärme zum Heizen
und Strom produziert.
Was für ein Job ist das für dich?
* Joël lacht. *
Ich mache das sehr gerne.
Vielleicht,
weil ich gerne Videospiele spiele.
Mit dem Joystick
fühlt man sich schnell wohl.
Meine Mutter meinte immer,
das Gamen bringe mir nichts,
aber jetzt konnte ich es doch
zu meinem Beruf machen.
Vor dir steht die Mutter von
drei Jungs: Du gibst mir Hoffnung.
Chef-Gamer Joël
auf seinem Technikthron.
Zum Schluss lässt er sogar
noch mich an die Joysticks.
Also, Achtung.
Runter ist ... Runter ist so, oder?
Ah, es ist wirklich wie gamen.
* Lachen *
Es ist alles sehr, sehr gross,
das muss ich sagen.
Ich war drei Tage
mit den Menschen unterwegs,
die unseren Abfall wegräumen.
Etwas, das ich mitnehme:
Wir alle sind so stolz
auf unsere saubere Schweiz,
also sollten wir auch stolz auf jene
sein, die sie so sauber machen.
Wow!
Perfekt.
* Lachen *
Okay.